tonight we bring begin our new crime
water series stories you won't see
anywhere else on television and we kick
off with a series on a suspected illegal
immigrant who can't seem to say no to
crime victory and Nez agreed to
cooperate with prosecutors two years ago
after he was allegedly found with
counterfeit prescription labels but that
didn't slow him down
yo Nez was charged with marijuana
possession and speeding last September
and when officers raided his
girlfriend's luxury condo two weeks
later they say he was brandishing an
ak-47 although yen as surrendered
peacefully officers say they found more
than 2,200 grams of marijuana more than
1,000 grams of the club drug Molly and
more than a hundred counterfeit
prescription labels let's bring in
someone who knows all the sordid details
Miami Herald reporter David Ave a David
great to see you this is a wild story I
read this this morning very early and it
does seem like it's something out of
Scarface tell me about this lovely
gentleman
well it's certainly something out of
Miami 2018 you know we've had a lot of
these cases of suspected drug dealers
and convicted drug dealers who are
younger younger folks these are not the
the stock and trade cocaine toughs from
the cocaine cowboy days of the 1980s but
these are younger people who are tech
savvy who you know know how to order
drugs from from from China from from the
internet from the dark web you know
people who know how to get marijuana
from States and where it's legal and
also know how to sell prescriptions
great prescription strength cough syrup
to a lot of the club scene down here so
it's it's sort of a new breed of drug
dealers in Miami it's not to say that
the the old cocaine days of the pass are
gone by any means but it's just there
and they're the cool crowd they're the
cool what I'm saying there's a cool
connected crowd you got his rapper
friend you you know he had some trouble
with the law you know back some years
ago not related to this and everybody's
connected and the connection to China I
think is
thing that Americans have no idea about
a very little idea about and the drug
trade from China with fentanyl and other
drugs is getting worse and worse I know
Miami's seen its share but talk about
how he managed to hook up with the
Chinese connection
well he's not charged with any of the
Chinese connections in this particular
case yet but certainly they found some
of the Mali drugs which are various
chemicals that are made in Chinese labs
and and basically sent over here through
the mail system disguised as different
packages if Miami Herald we did a series
a couple years ago called pipeline China
where we were we chronicled all the
different club drugs and the fence and
all coming over from China as easy as
going on the Internet and we had college
students we had veterans we had
strippers we had all these people that
were involved in in bringing these drugs
over to Miami making it one of the
largest synthetic drug capitals in the
in the country and and certainly one
that when the police raided his
girlfriend's house you know that was
something that they were investigating
so certainly is an interesting wrinkle
in an old time-honored way now I have a
question I have a question my only a few
seconds left but we keep hearing like
Lucas marijuana legalization we won't
have a marijuana problem but it was what
105 pounds of marijuana 105 pounds of
marijuana stuffed in three suitcases now
the feds are still the feds are still
investigating it but is believed to have
come from somewhere on the west coast
where marijuana all right well we're
gonna keep tracking this we're gonna
keep tracking this great reporting from
you and especially we're gonna be
following this China connection with the
drug trade as well underreported but
you're doing a great job